COLLEAGUE FROM WYOMING, MISS
CHENEY, FOR ANY OPENING
STATEMENTS SHE'D CARE TO OFFER.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MR.
CHAIRMAN.
LET ME TAKE JUST A FEW MINUTES
TODAY TO PUT THE TOPIC OF OUR
HEARING IN BROADER CONTEXT.
IN OUR LAST HEARING, WE HEARD
UNEQUIVOCAL TESTIMONY THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS TOLD HIS
ELECTION FRAUD ALLEGATIONS WERE
COMPLETE NONSENSE.
WE HEARD THIS FROM MEMBERS OF
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
WE HEARD THIS FROM PRESIDENT
TRUMP'S CAMPAIGN LAWYERS.
TRUMP'S FORMER ATTORNEY GENERAL,
BILL BARR.
WE HEARD THIS FROM PRESIDENT
TRUMP'S FORMER ACTING ATTORNEY
GENERAL, JEFF ROSEN.
AND WE HEARD THIS FROM PRESIDENT
TRUMP'S FORMER ACTING DEPUTY
ATTORNEY GENERAL, RICHARD
DONAHUE.
WE HEARD FROM MEMBERS OF
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S WHITE HOUSE
STAFF AS WELL.
TODAY WE'RE FOCUSING ON
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S RELENTLESS
EFFORT TO PRESSURE MIKE PENCE TO
REFUSE TO COUNT ELECTORAL VOTES
ON JANUARY 6TH.
HERE AGAIN IS HOW THE FORMER
VICE PRESIDENT PHRASED IT IN A
SPEECH BEFORE THE FEDERALIST
SOCIETY, A GROUP OF CONSERVATIVE
LAWYERS.
>> THIS WEEK THE PRESIDENT TRUMP
SAID I HAD THE RIGHT TO OVERTURN
THE ELECTION.
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS WRONG.
I HAD NO RIGHT TO OVERTURN THE
ELECTION.
THE PRESIDENCY BELONGS TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE, AND THE
AMERICAN ALONE.
AND FRANKLY, THERE IS NO IDEA
MORE UN-AMERICAN THAN THE NOTION
THAT ANY ONE PERSON COULD CHOOSE
THE AMERICAN PRESIDENT.
>> WHAT THE PRESIDENT WANTED THE
VICE PRESIDENT TO DO WAS NOT
JUST WRONG.
IT WAS ILLEGAL, AND
UNCONSTITUTIONAL.
WE WILL HEAR MANY DETAILS IN
TODAY'S HEARING, BUT PLEASE
CONSIDER THESE TWO POINTS.
FIRST, PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS TOLD
REPEATEDLY THAT MIKE PENCE
LACKED THE CONSTITUTIONAL AND
LEGAL AUTHORITY TO DO WHAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS DEMANDING HE
DO.
THIS IS TESTIMONY FROM MARK
SHORT, THE VICE PRESIDENT'S
CHIEF OF STAFF WHO SERVED IN THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION IN MULTIPLE
POSITIONS OVER FOUR YEARS.
>> JUST TO PICK UP ON THAT, MR.
SHORT, WAS IT YOUR IMPRESSION
THAT THE VICE PRESIDENT HAD
DIRECTLY CONVEYED HIS POSITION
ON THESE ISSUES TO THE
PRESIDENT, NOT JUST TO THE WORLD
THROUGH A DEAR COLLEAGUE LETTER,
BUT DIRECTLY TO PRESIDENT TRUMP?
>> MANY TIMES.
>> AND WAS HE CONSISTENT IN
CONVEYING HIS MESSAGE?
>> VERY CONSISTENT.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP PLOTTED WITH
A LAWYER JAMED JOHN EASTMAN TO
PRESSURE PENCE TO DO SO ANYWAY.
AS THE FEDERAL COURT HAS
EXPLAINED, QUOTE, BASED ON THE
EVIDENCE, THE COURT FINDS IT IS
MORE LIKELY THAN NOT THAT TRUMP
AND EASTMAN DISHONESTLY
CONSPIRED TO DISRUPT THE JOINT
SESSION OF CONGRESS ON
JANUARY 6TH, 2021.
WHAT EXACTLY DID PRESIDENT TRUMP
KNOW?
WHEN EXACTLY DID PRESIDENT TRUMP
KNOW THAT IT WOULD BE ILLEGAL
FOR MIKE PENCE TO REFUSE TO
COUNT ELECTORAL VOTES?
HERE IS ONE SAMPLE OF TESTIMONY
GIVEN BY ONE OF THE WITNESSES
BEFORE US TODAY.
THE VICE PRESIDENT'S GENERAL
COUNCIL.
>> DID JOHN EASTMAN EVER ADMIT,
AS FAR AS YOU KNOW, IN FRONT OF
THE PRESIDENT, THAT HIS PROPOSAL
WOULD VIOLATE THE ELECTORAL
CONDUCT?
>> I BELIEVE HE DID ON THE 4th.
>> THAT WAS JANUARY 4TH.
A FEW DAYS BEFORE THE ATTACK ON
CONGRESS.
A SECOND POINT, PLEASE LISTEN TO
TESTIMONY TODAY ABOUT ALL OF THE
WAYS THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP
ATTEMPTED TO PRESSURE VICE
PRESIDENT PENCE, INCLUDING
DONALD TRUMP'S TWEET AT
2:24 P.M., CONDEMNING VICE
PRESIDENT MIKE PENCE WHEN
PRESIDENT TRUMP ALREADY KNEW A
VIOLENT RIOT WAS UNDERWAY AT THE
CAPITOL.
IN FUTURE HEARINGS, YOU WILL
HEAR FROM WITNESSES WHO WERE
PRESENT INSIDE THE WHITE HOUSE.
WHO WERE PRESENT INSIDE THE WEST
WING ON THAT DAY.
BUT TODAY WE FOCUS ON THE
EARNEST EFFORTS OF MENACE WHO
WAS DETERMINED TO -- MIKE PENCE
WHO WAS DETERMINED.
AS VICE PRESIDENT PENCE PREPARED
A STATEMENT ON JANUARY 5TH AND
6th EXPLAINING THAT HE COULD NOT
ILLEGALLY REFUSE TO COUNT
ELECTORAL VOTES, HE SAID THIS TO
HIS STAFF.
>> THE VICE PRESIDENT SAID THIS
IS THE MOST THING I MAY EVER
SAY.
>> THIS IS A STATEMENT.
>> HE REALLY WANTED TO MAKE SURE
THAT IT WAS JUST SO.
>> YOU WILL HEAR TODAY THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S WHITE HOUSE
COUNCIL BELIEVED THE VICE
PRESIDENT DID EXACTLY THE RIGHT
THING ON JANUARY 6TH.
AS DID OTHERS IN THE WHITE
HOUSE, AS DID FOX NEWS HOST SEAN
HANNITY.
VICE PRESIDENT PENCE UNDERSTOOD
THAT HIS OATH OF OFFICE WAS MORE
IMPORTANT THAN HIS LOYALTY T